hey 42 here let's imagine for a moment
we're walking together down the streets
of a british town in the early part of
the 19th century
it's almost dawn and the gas street
lamps form yellow globes of light
in the early morning mist ahead we see a
figure begin to emerge from the haze
it appears to be human but from its body
extends a long
thin appendage that reaches high into
the gloom
is it an alien is that an antenna in its
pocket
or is it just pleased to see us no
it's a man and as he moves closer we see
he's carrying a long bamboo cane
that he uses to tap on the upper floor
window of each house that he passes
he's a knocker up also known as a
knocker upper
someone hired to wake people in the
morning to ensure they get to work on
time
not to be confused with the other type
of knocker upper
who does his job once and gets paid nine
months later
starting in the industrial era in the
times before reliable and cost-effective
alarm clocks
knocker ups were the people who got you
out of bed in the morning
charles dickens made reference to
knocking up in his novel
great expectations which makes sense
because life in victorian england
was pretty [ __ ] for most people it's no
surprise they needed a little extra
motivation to get the day started
times have changed but most of us still
find it hard to get going in the morning
if you really struggle to get out of bed
each day you may even have a condition
called dysania which although not yet
medically recognized is a near
near-complete inability to get out of
bed in the morning
that's fought to be linked to other
conditions like depression and chronic
fatigue syndrome
and if you have an overwhelming desire
to stay in bed
all day you might have a closely related
condition
called clinomania or you might just be
horribly hungover
regardless waking up overly tired is
usually a sign that something's wrong
or you're not getting enough proper
sleep which could simply be due to your
lifestyle
or perhaps one of approximately 80
different sleep disorders
for example if someone wakes you up
whilst you're in deep sleep
you'll probably feel a bit lost and
disorientated
if this response is particularly intense
or occurs regularly
you may be experiencing confusional
arousals
not to be mixed up with inappropriate
arousal which is a terrible affliction
experienced by teenage boys
at least three times a day confusional
arousal
is a condition in which you act in a
very strange or confused way
when you wake up episodes may involve
inappropriate behavior
shouting or an apparent inability to
wake up sounds like me on any normal day
but you can be sure to get a good
night's sleep when your balls are shaven
and nicely scented with manscaped who
have kindly sponsored this
video they sent over the all-in-one
performance package kit
let's take a look shall we i have to say
i'm pretty excited to try out this new
lawnmower 3.0
it's waterproof so you can maintain your
lawn in the shower
and it's got advanced skin safe
technology to help reduce any
nasty nicks and cuts manscaped have even
created what we've all been longing for
a deodorant for your balls it's called
crop preserver
this beauty is my favorite it's the weed
whacker nose and ear hair trimmer
this will come in very handy since i
haven't trimmed my nose hair since the
18th century
for a limited time you can get all of
this plus two free gifts
the shared travel bag which is super
handy and the lovely manscaped
anti-chafing boxer briefs
go to manscape.com today and get 20
off plus free international shipping
plus two free gifts
when you use promo code 42 at
manscape.com
your balls and body will thank you
other sleep disorders are even more
bizarre have you ever suffered from
exploding head syndrome although it
sounds like a scene from a quentin
tarantino film
it actually isn't quite as dramatic as
you might think sufferers of this
condition
hear a sudden and incredibly loud noise
like a gunshot
or a door slamming just as they're
drifting off to sleep
or as they wake up from a deep sleep
even though the room is completely
silent
every night you move through several
sleep cycles
with each cycle having five stages
four stages of non-rapid eye movement or
non-rem sleep and one stage
of rem sleep it is during rem sleep that
you experience
dreams and to stop you acting out those
fantasies in the real world
and eating your alarm clock mistaking it
for your dream cheeseburger
your brain temporarily paralyzes your
body
a process called atonia sleep paralysis
happens when you gain consciousness
before your body has moved
fully out of the rapid eye movement or
rem stage of sleep
and if you've ever experienced it you'll
know it can be absolutely terrifying
in this state you're semi-awake or even
fully awake but completely unable to
move
a muscle and as if total immobility
weren't enough
there's even stranger symptoms of this
surprisingly common condition
as many as 40 of people experience sleep
paralysis at some point in their lives
and many recall sensing a presence
nearby
or even on top of them during the period
of paralysis
causing a feeling of intense pressure on
their chest
and an inability to breathe that
presence
has taken many forms usually shaped by
the cultural beliefs of the time
characters have ranged from witches to
trolls to ghosts
to harvey weinstein but aliens
are the most popular nighttime chest
sitters
in the modern era the condition is
believed to be the origin of the incubus
or succubus myths which warn of demons
that attack during the night
usually sexually sleep paralysis is also
thought to have been the inspiration for
the famous 18th century painting
by henry fusley no relation to the
pastor by the way
called the nightmare which shows a
goblin sitting on the stomach of a
sleeping woman
confusional arousals exploding head
syndrome and sleep paralysis
are all examples of parasomnias
a broad group of sleep disorders that
involve weird things happening whilst
you're falling asleep
sleeping or waking up they can include
strange dreams
emotions movements or behaviors and most
of them happen during non-rem sleep
they can sometimes be traumatic for the
person involved or the people they live
with
but for the most part these conditions
are fairly harmless
take sleep talking for instance sure you
may say a few embarrassing things out
loud whilst asleep on the train
but seriously if you like rubbing peanut
butter on your nipples
you shouldn't be embarrassed to tell the
world about it whilst unconscious
or how about sleep sex also known as sex
omnia nothing wrong with wanting to get
your jollies off mid-slumber is there
then there's sleep walking everyone
knows someone with a funny sleepwalking
story
but surely apart from the risk of
walking into things
pissing in your cupboard or falling down
stairs
it's all just a bit of fun isn't it well
yes most manifestations of parasomnias
have little impact in the wider world
but in some
alarming cases they have ended in
violent even fatal criminal acts being
committed
under the supposed blanket of sleep the
defendants in these cases
have sworn they were asleep when
committing their crimes
and knew nothing of their actions an
argument that has come to be known
as the sleepwalking defense sleepwalking
technically known as somnambulism
usually occurs during slow wave sleep
the deepest stages of non-rem sleep
exactly what causes it isn't known but
essentially
the brain seems to get stuck between
sleep and wakefulness
recently some researchers have provided
an alternative theory
that instead of being awake or asleep
sleepwalkers
are both at the same time in what might
be
a new type of state dissociation with
consciousness and unconsciousness
switching rapidly and
continuously either way sleepwalkers can
do a lot more than walk
they may sit up and look around pick up
objects around the home
take a stroll out of the house or even
drive
there's a common myth that you shouldn't
wake a sleepwalker
when in fact leaving someone to
sleepwalk
can lead to disastrous even homicidal
consequences
as we're about to find out the first
legal record of sleepwalking being used
as a successful defense
was in the united states in 1846
in what became known as the boston
tragedy
albert terrell slits the throat of the
woman he'd left his wife for
a prostitute named maria bickford almost
decapitating her in the process
then just to prove he meant business he
set fire to the brothel
and fled to new orleans where he was
arrested
in court his lawyer argued that terrell
was a long-time
and chronic sleepwalker and perhaps
committed to crime whilst asleep
and the jury obviously thought it was a
plausible story
because tyrell was acquitted
in 1887 esteemed paris detective
robert ledry was sent to normandy to
help solve an ongoing case
he arrived at night and went to bed
early but woke the next morning to find
his shoes and socks
was soaked through he also discovered
the case he'd been assigned to
was no longer a priority because during
the night
there had been a mudder a murder
i a mudder a prominent businessman had
been shot on the beach
with no clues as to why ledrew
investigated taking plaster casts of the
footprints that led to the corpse
he was naturally more than a little
surprised to discover
the footprints exactly matched
his own and combined with his
inexplicably wet socks and shoes
he came to the startling conclusion he
was the murderer despite having no
recollection
whatsoever of the crime his findings
were confirmed by ballistics testing
and he was imprisoned for his own good
during his incarceration
prison guards gave him a gun loaded with
blanks
and one night la drew suddenly got up
and started
firing at the men guarding his cell it
was enough to convince the authorities
that he was a homicidal sleepwalker
and not a cold-blooded killer luxury was
moved to a secluded farm outside of
paris
and kept there until his death 50 years
later
perhaps the most well-known of these
cases occurred in 1987 when kenneth
parks
a young canadian man was acquitted of
murder
on the grounds of sleepwalking one night
parks climbed into his car and drove 14
miles to his parents-in-law's house
where he proceeded to strangle beat
and stab his mother and father-in-law
with whom he apparently had close
relationships
his mother-in-law was killed and his
father-in-law
seriously injured afterwards still
dripping with blood
parks drove to a police station and
confessed to the crimes
but witnesses said he appeared confused
about what had happened
he had also severed tendons in both his
hands during the attack
and should have been feeling intense
pain but
he seemed altogether unaware of his
injuries
at the trial the jury was convinced
parks
had indeed been unconscious at the time
and he was found
not guilty more recently in 2008
british man brian thomas was accused of
the murder of his wife
who he admitted he'd strangled in the
back of their
campervan thomas couldn't remember what
had happened
but thought he had been dreaming that
his wife was an intruder
the prosecution eventually withdrew the
charges
and the judge said that thomas wasn't
responsible for his actions
but before you start planning to bump
off that annoying guy at work who
always steals your parking space before
giving an exaggerated yawn and claiming
you were asleep the whole time
it's worth bearing in mind not everyone
gets away with the sleepwalking defense
in 1997 in phoenix arizona
scott felter stabbed his wife 44 times
with a hunting knife
his neighbor also testified to seeing
him drag his wife's body to the pool
before holding her head underwater
falater
claimed to have been asleep at the time
saying he had a history of sleepwalking
and had been sleep deprived in the
run-up to the incident
the prosecution argued falater had tried
to hide evidence of the murder
in a way that was too complex to have
been achieved whilst asleep
and in between the stabbing and the
drowning a neighbor also saw
felita motion to his dog to lie down
which was considered
a possible sign of consciousness a jury
found him guilty of first degree murder
in 1999. in spain in 2001 antonio nito
brutally killed his
wife and mother-in-law his daughter and
son tried to stop him and
both received severe injuries for their
efforts
nito told the court he had been asleep
during the attack
and had been dreaming he was defending
himself
against aggressive ostriches full marks
for inventiveness there antonio
but his children said he had recognized
them during the attack
and had even told them not to turn the
light on because their mother
who had already been brutally assaulted
was supposedly
sleeping nito was sentenced to 10 years
in a psychiatric facility
these are only a few of more than 100
examples of apparent sleep-related
violence that have been reported in the
last century or so
which include instances of homicide
assault and sexual assault
for a long time doctors and lawyers
lumped all types of bizarre sleep
violence under the heading of
sleepwalking
but there was a distinct difference
between somnambulism
and another type of parasomnia rem
behaviour disorder
or rbd rem behaviour disorder happens
during rem sleep while someone is
dreaming
but instead of the muscles being
paralyzed as usual
the dreamer's body is still active and
they're able to act out their dreams
when they're woken up they can usually
remember fragments of the dream they
were in
this is different from sleepwalkers who
operating from
non-rem sleep usually have no
recollection of what happened
once they're woken and are in general
more confused and disorientated
nambulism and rbd are quite different
but
i for one wouldn't be overly interested
in the semantics
if someone in a night gown was chasing
me with an axe
so why do these distinctions matter
in the end they helped to determine the
tricky business of truth
up until fairly recently it was
impossible to test whether someone was
telling the truth when they claimed to
have been asleep
during a violent episode traditionally
courts have relied on historical and
circumstantial evidence to make the call
sleepwalking for example is partly
genetic and sufferers of rbd
or somnamilism often have a history of
the condition
sleep deprivation stress alcohol and
drugs can also make someone more
susceptible to an episode
sleepwalking is also often triggered by
a sound heavy snoring being the most
common
all of these points have in the past
being used as indicators
as to whether a defendant is telling the
truth
but technological advancements have made
it possible for scientists to make
accurate assessments about whether
someone is a genuine sleepwalker
or just a sleep liar free lab tests are
used to assess when someone is in
different stages of sleep
the first an electroencephalogram eeg
records brain activity in the form of
waves the second
an electro-oculogram eog detects
eye movements and finally an
electromyogram
emg measures muscle activity via a
sensor placed on the chin
or an arm or a leg of course the number
of people who've committed a crime
whilst asleep
and wearing these sensors is pretty low
okay zero so we don't have definitive
proof of whether a potential murderer
was asleep
or not when they acted violently but
being able to retrospectively assess
people's sleep patterns can help to
establish
probability because you know if someone
goes to sleep every night repeatedly
slapping his penis as he drifts off
he's probably more partial to a spot of
sleep murder
than someone who sleeps like a log noro
imaging studies have also started to
advance our understanding of how
sleepwalking works
claudio bessetti of the university of
zurich has examined the brains of
sleepwalkers
using single photon emission
computerized tomography
or spect he has discovered that in
sleepwalking states
your brain's cerebrum and cerebral
cortex
the clever parts of your brain that
decide the difference between right and
wrong
shuts down your brain becomes directed
by more primitive
and automatic functions the kind
connected to hunger sex and survival
from a legal point of view it confirms
that sleepwalkers and sufferers of rbd
are not conscious when they're asleep
and
so cannot be considered to have men's
rare
which is the intention to commit a crime
and is typically required for someone to
be found guilty
we're still some way off from having a
foolproof way of deciding whether or not
someone was
genuinely asleep when they committed
some terrible act of violence
but we do now know that it is a real
thing so
until we understand more it might be an
idea to hide the kitchen knives
before you switch the lights off each
night and of course
sleep well thanks again to manscaped for
sponsoring this video
don't forget to check them out the links
in the description below